but we begin this morning with the big
winter storm that's heading across the
country this weekend an estimated 60
million americans are in the path of
what's being called a saskatchewan
screamer named for the canadian province
where the storm originated at least 27
states stretching from kansas to georgia
have winter weather advisories posted
this morning the storm dumped snow on
the plains and midwest on friday and is
expected to impact the southeast and
mid-atlantic by the start of the work
week elise preston has more from the
mississippi river city of moline
illinois
the travel headache started early on
friday these roads in iowa got a thick
coating of snow and ice more than 400
plow trucks were out friday in the
hawkeye state alone this truck flipped
on the interstate north of des moines
and the driver of this car was hurt
after losing control and rolling off the
highway out in the open spaces out there
everything drifts over so it's real hard
to be able to get through here in moline
illinois people watched a steady
snowfall in other parts of the region
heavy snow fell an inch an hour like in
eastern minnesota where wind gusts of up
to 20 miles per hour made life difficult
for anyone trying to keep the streets
clear the wind will make
life a whole lot worse for us
i mean keep up the snow but the wind's
not going to be your friend at all
that's the closest thing we have
are the shovels preparations for the
snow are underway in atlanta a city that
hasn't seen significant snowfall in four
years but has struggled through past
storms mayor andre dickens says his city
is ready this is about public safety the
public interest and making sure that the
business of the city can continue as
necessary so
getting it right is important for all
eyes always being on atlanta and
transportation officials in virginia are
trying to get it right they began
pre-treating roadways on thursday in an
effort to avoid scenes like we saw
earlier this month when snow and ice
caused a 40-mile backup that stranded
hundreds of drivers on interstate 95.
and with the storm approaching the east
coast shoppers are already stocking up
we are prepared we started preparing
days ago for
the
forecast that was coming down the pike
for cbs saturday morning elise preston
molina illinois